hey guys Justin here we're gonna be
playing some Mega Man Legacy Collection
today I'm joined on the couch by editor
Matty Spinelli and two guys from Capcom
Ray Jimenez Brett Elston now of course
you guys didn't make Megaman no so what
are your rules on the Mega Man Legacy
Collection so I'm the producer here in
the US that's working on the project I'm
working directly with the dev team over
in Emeryville that's making a game for
us and Brett yeah I'm community manager
for Megaman so running like the social
media accounts but also just been
helping out playing the game looking at
the challenges looking at fan feedback
all summer and yeah and today I'm
helping demo the games then yeah we've
had a lot of Megaman collections over
the years what is it that that is Mega
Man Legacy Collection what's different
about this it's actually funny that you
bring up making my collection because I
actually worked on the one on the ps2
GameCube an exponent Xbox their first
Xbox so you know I'm very familiar with
you know what we've done before and and
especially how this one is different
this one the actual so in essence it's
Mega Man 1 through 6 it's all the
original digital baby there's no 8-bit
games it's the the 8-bit legacy that
like Capcom has what what's really
different about this particular
collection is that these are striving
more for authenticity and reproduction
and all the other ones were the other
ones were like how can we bring our
classic game but kind of add some cool
things to it that that the gamers kind
of expect the core game themselves for
us here aside from looking an extremely
sharp due to the because we can reach up
with them at an HD resolution we're
striving to have everything as authentic
as it as they can be everything is gonna
play the same every every slowdown
everything just just about everything
that you remember should be there that's
definitely our goal the guys that we're
working with there their goal when they
approached us with this project is
because they had some technology that
can do this very quickly and accurately
was to to to archive our original games
to to because like for instance of the
the ps2 versions they're the collection
because it doesn't have its emulated in
a way that's not exactly perfect there's
no original version of our game out
there
more and he wanted to bring one they
wanted to bring an original version of
the NES classics back to back now so now
we have this this version forever going
forward so even more so than that that
ps2 version playing these games is gonna
be like plugging in that NES cartridge
in yes yeah and then this is like really
just so we can have an original version
sitting somewhere we actually I have the
yeah so what kind of objects it looks
like yeah of course you're gonna have a
lot of different things you're able to
do because you're on right hardware
what kind of extra options are you right
so I'll put the start off on the default
options and and it kind of goes to
speaks to how authentic to trying to
make everything so this is no filter
just straight out put it at an HD
resolution so all it's still a bit don't
get me wrong but it's still but it's
extremely crisp and this is what's
called the original modi you'll notice
that there's black borders on the left
and right side as well as a popping
bottom that is so that we can display
this in the original NES aspect ratio
without any stretching so everything
would be as smoothing as Christmas as we
can actually display without but on the
new monitors with the new with all the
pixels inside you when you move it up to
full this kind of this will take that
same aspect ratio but stretch it to fill
the top and bottom so it'll have it'll
look it'll have the same aspect ratio
but there'll be a little bit of
stretching so it may not be ideal for
some folks and then we also have a
widescreen so if you wanted to actually
feel both the vertical and the
horizontal you can choose to I honestly
don't like it well because I know we
know that that would be we use that one
thing so when we felt that you know
there were some visual conceits that
we're willing to do that are still
within the realm of authentic play but
whereas if you go in and start trying to
like make the game actually display more
like it starts breaking how the game was
put together where a lot of Megaman is a
square room and a square room and a
square room and if you were actually
gonna like redraw it to fill and it
becomes like a very different experience
what is it like recreating a game that
some of the reasons that we remember it
being
maybe janky or having problems was
because of limitations on the hardware
but when you don't have those
limitations how do you recreate that you
just so so things disappearing or yeah
so so that's actually kind of
interesting comments your bottom so
we're not actually recreating it though
we're using the original assets in the
game so we're the the method that we're
doing here was actually me reshaped play
upon each other yeah this is a hard game
to play on talking when you say like
it's it's like the NES it means but
better than like it oh yeah yeah so
that's actually particular question
comment about the hardware limitations
so there's two kinds of slowdown in the
game there is
there's slowdown that happened just
because the NES was a super powerful
piece of machine but then also there's a
most of the most of the slowdown was
actually programmatically put into the
game
and it said that if if you're playing if
you're playing on the game and you know
this many enemies on the screen the game
the game itself will slow down now that
is still in the game we have preserved
that in there and but the the slowdown
that's created by the hardware is gone
of course because you're not on the
original hardware I've seen a lot of
requests like oh we should take it out
or there should be an option to take it
out one of the things that we're doing
is that the technique that the
developers using in order to make
everything very authentic and do this
really quickly
they're not quickly and accurately
limits us from being able to really dig
in and changing this kind of this kind
of programming so we can't we can't
really take out the slowdown and the
flicker without changing how we're
creating the game itself and how we're
creating the game makes it accurate so
in the in the philosophy of making
everything is accurate not nice again
trying to get greedy we've decided that
we're just gonna be some hardline and
make everything original that
so what was your your favorite game to
work on I I mean we all have different
points I think where we came in and like
what our first megaman game was right
like mine was of course the first Mega
Man uh-huh well what was your favorite
one to work on which one was the most um
III think and then it's not really the
most populous but I really like five
five oh wow I like five ah you know it
kind of hit that bridge of where people
were really getting comfortable with NES
and able to do like some things that you
wouldn't believe we're still 8-bit but
it look I'm the most 16-bit so it was it
was really cool that so my that was my
personal thing I I really I really I
like I like like that crash man I just
like crash man that charge man
I like charge man I don't know why he's
a train head really quick all right so
there's something I liked about
comparing even to the 2004 collection
like this the in-and-out speed of
getting in between each game is like way
faster than you could change the cart
like it's yeah basically you know like
effective video loading it's like you're
in and out really quick it's so looking
at the games why well drove the decision
to only put titles 1 through 6 instead
of something that's more comprehensive
yeah so so the developer working with as
I mentioned they had they had this
really cool tech that was really good at
quickly and accurately reproducing and
esq but the thing is right it's only on
NES so it there what what they have
doesn't work for the SNES or the
PlayStation at this moment so we
couldn't really do all of them so our
focus right now is as the the NES
classics I mean in a way in a way that
this title would be could be act more
accurately called the RR 8-bit legacy as
opposed to the Megaman legacy because
what we're really sticking to that sure
the true 8-bit games itself is there any
plans or or do you guys see this as
something that you would expand within
this game or or if we were gonna see
another collection of the other mega man
games would that come as a separate
title
I really haven't figured out ha you know
where we go from here you know
if we're gonna leverage what would they
what the developer is able to do we
would probably move on to more NES games
first before we do anything else and
that's but that's that out that all
depends on you know it we believe
there's a market for and want for the
preservation of our old games and and
and not just to have the 8-bit games but
to have them exactly like as we had it
before but you know that being said you
know we're not we're not just giving you
the games ourselves we had good hat off
add a lot of content to the to this
particular to this particular game and
actually one really cool thing that cuz
I mentioned I really liked charge man if
oh yeah thanks for me so when you go to
when you go to Mega Man 5 you can go to
the database and this actually probably
talked about while this text came from
yeah so a lot of this text I guess this
is the first time this was like
officially localized these these enemy
descriptions from was it from those ps1
as from the ps1 Rockman yeah it works
yeah so this is the first time we've
actually brought that text over and as
you move through the database you can
see like not just a production art and
and the names for all these enemies but
also in the corner there on the left you
can see like the ideal weapon to use
against them a weakness napalm bomb from
the napalm man you have to learn the
icons but yeah but the the real like
attraction here is when you scroll
through you'll get eventually get to the
robot masters that the ain't bosses of
the game and the cool thing about the
databases you can just jump right in
from here and crash man practice
regiment I in practice so you see I see
fight on the bottom of the screen there
yeah yeah so I see that he's uh he's
weak to whatever the wrong that's the
that is the power stone the pop from
stone man so so when you all in here
depression is a renter does it
automatically give you the thing that
he's weak against yeah so you can't you
can you can basically learn his pattern
attack pattern before you have to try to
fight him so you'd have to go to the
whole game and try to figure out as a
tag that was just I'm looking at doing
uh you can only hurt him when he's like
still basically yeah I knew that he's
just if he's angry red it won't hurt
and then I think when he's even let's
try that again actually you like you got
him do you get the you get a fun jingle
when you lose but this is a way for like
like for me like one of my thing I like
the most about all these games were the
bosses and they're all learning the
patterns learning the weapons to use
against them but for new players it
might be kind of frustrating like if you
if you if it's been 20 years since
you've played these or maybe never this
is a good way to like okay well let me
get this guy down and then I'll jump in
the game and do it for real wait because
since it is a these are like 80s 90s
games you get like three tries then you
got to continue you start back already
it alone right so it's a challenge but
it's one of those games like all six of
them are really good about like teaching
you things in a safe environment and
then testing you more more more so it's
not hard and just like an unfair
punishing way it's hard in like a to pay
attention and get better kind of way and
the game also introduces some state
states which are popular among horrible
players like myself Oh No yeah yeah you
can you can save and then load kind of
on the fly and then in the same pause
menu as the filters and stuff but it's
more it's what for folks who like just
want to see the whole game like or you
know you're playing and you got to go
somewhere and you don't know I just I
don't want to turn it off is that it is
that individual teaching like I say if I
was playing Mega Man - could I set it
safe state for that and then go play
another Mega Man games come back to Mega
Man yes we have we have we have one per
game okay it I firstly I I think it
takes away from when I like to play I
try not to use it unless I'm having to
get up and leave somewhere but a we know
you know that users would be able to
would want it it was something we were
able to do she one cool thing that we
didn't touch showed is a museum which is
Brett had mentioned production art which
as it sounds it's like a lot of art that
was created during the production of it
of the game itself
in addition to that we do have these
cool character files which are say like
if we wanted to pick up any wanted to
make a beat we would send mashite kind
of giving all the colors and give them a
turn around and
these are like the official licensing
sheets for each character which are cool
because a lot of those characters you
never see the back so a lot of the boss
like robot master designs you see like
oh I didn't know they have like Vince
and yeah it's a pretty cool old stuff we
were able to find and the developer
actually had gone out to museums to find
cuz you know we may have these but you
don't have them the high college scan
because we did scan them back in the 80s
so it's not that great dpi but they went
out and fine went to museums and found
these actual ads and scanned them and
these huge format you know some of these
files are 500 megabytes they're gigabyte
for an image of a scan of from a
magazine so these are really cool so all
the games that we have these kinds of
things for you able to find makes them
cool some cool content that way as well
and going back to the boss battle being
able to go through the different boss
robots - does that include the dr.
Wily's in-game creations as well duh
when you're going against while eating
have the mini bosses I know we were only
doing for the robot master that was
actually kind of a challenge we wanted
to do include like so we have the robot
masters here but then for this
particular game like this taco trash and
metal daddy
there were weird so we have a lot of
limitations of what we could do in the
game because since the game is kind of
running its own little module we can't
detect everything that's going on so we
actually had a really hard time
determining when you finished fighting
say you fit when you finished fighting
Paco trash the game didn't really say oh
you were done now so this is this is one
that's over so we could only really keep
that to the robot masters but is that
absolutely something we were thinking
about in the release setup for this is a
little bit different than them uh some
others there's gonna be a digital
release and coming after that is the
physical release how is that rolling now
exactly yeah so the digital one for Xbox
one ps4 and PC digital launches
August 25th those hit first and then
afterwards we have a 3ds version in the
winter accompanied by a digital 3ds
version accompanied by physical versions
of ps4 Xbox one and 3ds in early 2016
so basically digital first and then
discs come a little later but is the 3ds
version
to have the same feature said like
everything that's included on the
historic strikes one as well or will
that be dialed down a little bit this
should be the exact same you like
features yeah play like the challenge
mode like we're doing here the museum
all that stuff oh you can talk about
that I kind of just jump jumped into
this so what is this yeah the challenge
mode will take like little scenes from
you know it'll give you a theme at the
beginning like this is a Megaman to like
test and a Mega Man 1 and to mash up
kind of like a nes remix sort of like
that yeah only this is rather than
taking like you know here's some sprites
from six that are now fighting you in
Mega Man 2 and are playing for with no
slide or something like that it's more
like these sequences that are now you
know put together to challenge like
experienced players in a way that like
so even if someone who knows like scene
by scene like where I'm at what I'm
doing in a given second of a Mega Man
game some of these you're not used to
like going through this section of air
man and then you blink and all of a
sudden you're like you know you're in
Wiley Wiley 2 of Mega Man 1 you like
what I or wherever you go so now you're
in wooden man stage yeah but some of the
like there was a really cool thing I
watched one of his speed when his dude
say I told you messed it up but it was a
way to / quick way to bypass this it was
you know it's just one of the cool
things about this mode is that we were
able to provide replays with any of this
the first time that we have here so if I
get a good time you can not only watch
to replay locally but if they say
they're attached to the leaderboard so
you can kind of lifestyle like you know
some of the best speed runners in the
game actually gonna get to these
challenges you know so I'm guessing this
this challenge was was like a Mega Man
to like test we're gonna bounce you
around Mega Man 2 but then there's also
like we're gonna take pieces of one and
two and then you'll you'll have to like
remember certain abilities or weapons
that you have in this scene like the
Magna beam remembering that you even
have the Magna beam and
one that and can save a ton of time but
then later you'll like mix 3 and 4 or 2
or 1 1 through 6 and you have to
remember like moments a moment ok I have
a slide now ok now I don't have the
slide ok I've been charging Buster and I
don't have a tripping goes so some of it
is like it comes so fast that you're
like have to like ricochet your mind
around a lot but that's why they'll be
really fun to watch those leaderboards
and some of those the video replays to
see how people deal with it because
there should be some pretty creative
solutions to these challenges
yeah like using these and picking the
right time needs to flash the flash
stopper in order to get through that
that particular section it has an
instance where well yeah I guess it is
wily so I was thinking metalman stage
but that's an example of like if it was
metalman stage which is a similar
scenario with the drills I wouldn't
normally have flash man's weapon there
because I would have maybe gun the metal
man first usually to get the metal blade
it's definitely something more aimed at
the hardcore people who know this game
backwards in front yeah yeah it's one of
the decisions that we came with it's
like we could we could we could
determine like we could only give you a
particular weapon to give you a
particular challenge of getting to this
area with a weapon but I think we found
that if we gave everybody everything
then you could be more creative in how
you get through them any more options
that's one of my favorites is the quick
man beam section just how fast like
basically as soon as it starts the
second portion of it if you're not
already holding left you're dead like
it'll show up in the middle of a long
sequence and then you're like okay
what's next okay you have just enough
time to like cuss out loud and then but
when you die you don't have it's not
like it boots you back out you got to do
the whole thing over from scratch it's
just it's more time test so it'll start
you right back at the part of the
challenge we're in so what drove the
decision to to bring this back now why
go after the original Mega Man legacy
though one of the six games
so the actual illness wasn't the
developer can us said hey we've been
working on this technology never I've
actually worked with him before under my
old on other titles Capcom Classics
Collection which is our arcade games
they had come to us and say hey we've
been working or finalizing with this
really cool technology that were able to
accurately reproduce NES games uh let's
talk and see what we can do so we
discussed you know we export our pretty
good a particular library and what would
be a cool set to do and you know
obviously Megaman was just kind of like
it made sense it's like let's do all of
our Megaman games and then and then from
there you know we can we can see what we
do from there but Megaman as a package
was just more attractive to internally
and externally it's like if we were
gonna do if for whatever he's really did
one pack of these NES games what would
people want to see in it and Megaman
absolutely
you know everyone still likes Megaman
inside and outside of Capcom and you
know we want we wanted to see a new one
so when you'd collection come in so here
this is how we kind of decided to do two
Megaman but it was absolutely the
developer coming to us and saying hey we
got this really cool way to do it
I mean you typically don't see a whole
lot of until you know super recently a
whole lot of NES game games ported it's
it's normally not a very cost-effective
thing to do reporting is can be
expensive and doing ironing this game
can can be expensive as well so I think
part of that is also we see so many
indie games that that take this same
style that it's no longer like 8-bit
it's this is what modern some modern
games look like and then the way people
are making them and it's interesting
because Capcom also has a huge library
of NES games from that time like oh yeah
really the possibilities for some other
fun collections I think could be
exciting for for Capcom fans right right
and you know we believe that you know
the same fans that would want to play
that want to play Mega Man wouldn't want
to see other things in the future - so I
you know I I hope I can we can prove all
of our bosses rights
you know like we I know we wanted to do
Megaman first and look how populous is
going to be so when you have that
leaderboard there how does it how do you
show up it like is it friends base is it
locally on the the console or is there a
right so Kappa yeah we can't show you it
cuz you're not connected but yeah but
you go to leaderboard it would just show
you the best times you know from went to
whatever you can you can sort by your
friends you can sort sort by your own
score and I believe it's the top 100
will have a replay attached to it so you
can watch any of those guys but it's all
tops off hundred of all time or top 100
of all time yeah so this is actually a
replay of I think one of our some we
were demoing the game for and they were
giving it a run through and I think this
might be the demo where I was like
explaining that the the pause glitch you
know exploit still works in this version
or this might be one where they do not
succeed other there the try me they're
gonna get shot okay so here we go so
famously and Megaman one the elect beam
is like a great silly weapon that each
time you want to pause it resets the
damage and you can as long as its hitbox
is still overlapping a target you can
just cheese pretty much in it we're
there any other intentional glitches
that you kept in the game like that so
every every glitch and cheap that we can
is in that that we know of with one
exception that may or may not make it in
there it's just because it's kind of
weird and hard to do now was it Mega Man
3 yeah Mega Man 3 if you put in a
controller a second controller and hit
right on the d-pad you could get a super
jump for Mega Man controllers I had a
way differently okay modern consoles now
so we've been trying to on it last I
heard it was in it but I haven't seen it
myself so I'm out so I'm hesitant to say
that it definitely did in there but but
I it's something that we're aware of but
everything else that we have we are
aware of is working because the way is
developed is that it technically it
should be there and everything we've
been able to confirm like Brett was
saying that he he was
to reproduce as if which is basically
you do this weird glitch and then you're
zipped over to another section of the
game it's something I've never done
before but he's able to produce it I've
seen people that at Comicon do them yeah
so I I know they're in there but in
theory without us having been able to
confirm every single one just because of
lack of skill or knowledge the way it's
developed that they all should all be
there naturally I mean that's a lot
harder to to try to keep glitches in
that try to yeah well yeah we're not
we're not actually programming them in
they just naturally be there and from
what we've seen
they all have all been there there's
just there that one controller one is
the one kind of everything because it's
dependent Donna on how you can consoles
work in which I mean I remember the days
working on just even as you know ps2
when you just had control one and
control two and now but now there's all
these profiles and signing in and
signing out and it makes things so
complicated I kind of miss just plugging
in controller and then you have it
that's really good at proto man he's got
that chunk timing nice Oh sly mix scam
patient will this also be a I would
assume a little bit cheaper not uh not a
full price game or oh yes yeah we're
swish or selling it for $15 on the
digital version oh well your guess is
it's very reasonably priced yeah
Oh show my filter you haven't shown any
Coakley oh yeah so so we have TV which
is more like approximating like an old
like CRT that's like really given up the
ghost yeah it's a lot of blur like like
the colors are like breaking the borders
or like just super fuzzy and actually I
noticed too usually if you stand still
with a Mega Man mmm I don't know if this
is intentional because there there was a
guy at the developer doesn't working
really hard on that filter if he stands
still you'll see kind of like a pixel
flicker on and off on him mmm I don't
know it's it's it's very it's very like
he's put a lot of effort into into
making him look right
I think over by his shoulder yeah yeah
there's like a pixel flickering and oh
yeah he's kind of ship and he's also
fringed left under after that yeah yeah
most image yeah the ghost thing is like
my favorite part of this it just reminds
me of like playing old arcade games on a
monitor or TV that's like you guys
really should replace this and we do
also have have another have another
filter that's it's the same thing but
we've taken away that the CRT ness of it
that so the scan lines are there as if
you're playing more on an arcade that
that wasn't so terrible so or if you're
playing for those that played on
different screens yeah but but that
still had pixels there scan lines are
there but the the blurring is gone is
ricky'll it's definitely very
reminiscent of me being a kid and
playing this on my terrible TV right it
makes me wonder like having all these
memories of playing with NES back in the
day and how fuzzy really was like trying
to like really remember like here's in
my mind I'm like oh yeah crystal clear
like what are you talking about I'm like
man I bet it was a mess because I'm I
think about like playing mode Gameboy
like like oh yeah I was fine and then
I'm like oh man it was it was tough on
so and once you successfully get past
this I think one of the other features
guys had was also a sound test mode like
being able to go through all the music
for though yep the games in the title so
how does that work is it only within the
game is it something where you'd be able
to make me shut it off and just like
play in the background yeah so it's
accessible from the the main menu and
you can it's all split up by the
different six games and in all the
tracks are there and it's actually it's
actually really cool is because we're
not playing WAV files are not playing
mp3 is we're actually when you select
title track for Megaman 3 in the
background the game is booting up and
playing that that track from the actual
game itself you just don't see the
picture so Bret has a really awesome
technique for this that I I cannot do
that it seemed that sounds easy it's
like every time I'm like oh this is
super easy and it's like what if you get
like one second off it's like he just
whales on yak because once you get in a
hit stun you're off my stuff yeah so
that's actually really cool so you're
listening to a music player that's just
busy playing the game without a picture
free I thought that was really cool
and some people may ask me why would you
just want to do that it it basically it
was a way for us to not have to find a
music player to put in the game so then
we can just we were just using the game
assets itself because I mean every
everything if you're gonna do if you
want to show movies you got to put a
movie player you know like people see
that [ __ ] logo cuz that's a video player
and same thing for sounding if you
wanted to play music and mp3 wave wave
wave file you would have to either
develop develop your own music player or
licensed one and you know we just wanted
to keep things economical for the
developer and totally their idea and
they just like oh we're just well just
play the game with that without a
picture man he is ready - ready - ready
to fight here yeah he's like one of
those guys - which one should get kind
of on tilt on him you kind of well
sometimes he'll just like hanging all
the way over on the right and all the
time he's like nope I'm coming right
right for you I guess yeah we should
actually up out of that and go to that
music players just talked about oh yeah
one through six
yeah I mean what's a good one stone is
pretty good yeah so they're just gonna
like a loop to like if you just hit
enter this is gonna look through them
people and I'll play from front front to
back the way the the
that the games work as I think there's a
little palm was kind of trying to loop
it back and forth between a different
asset check so to play one at a time
you'd have to start it again it one
thing I think I've seen on some other
3ds games is the ability to fly plug in
headphones turn on the music player shut
the Kaizen like is that something that
you guys are working on or is that still
to a little bit early that's not a bad
idea you know we're still working on it
so I that was that's something that is
going later it's that's not a bad idea
thank you for mentioning it yeah no I
thought that was a really cool features
like turn on the music player and it's
like having an effete 3 player but for
the video game right which title that
what's that mom that is definitely
something I will consider but yeah
something that we couldn't do do for
this particular game I mean we
absolutely wanted to make as robust as
we can but you know that's since we're
still working on the three distance it's
not released until later that's a very
good thing back do well hopefully that
is a feature we'll get to see and but
people are gonna be able to play this
pretty soon that next month like you
said August 15 25 2015 it's gotta be
also pretty pretty exciting that you're
gonna be able to get this out of the way
get it out there yeah focus on the
really hard part the physical ones so
really exciting thanks so much for
coming by showing us the Mega Man Legacy
Collection Mega Man's one through six
coming August 25th and you know really
exciting stuff uh nothing
super new it seems we know before but
being able to experience them in I think
the ways that we did when we were kids
and for people that weren't alive then
getting to see you know what it was like
being a kid back in the 80s and 90s so
really exciting stuff thanks so much for
joining us it was Ray Jimenez bred
Elston and Matt Espen Ellie thanks so
much thank you
you